Ukrainian officials report explosions
in and around the Russian occupied
cities of Verdansk and Mariupol.
They say at least five strikes targeted
Russian positions in Verdansk on Sunday.
And one official says the explosions
in Mariupol caused casualties
but gave no further details.
Meanwhile, the Ukrainian military
says Russia
launched one of its largest
drone attacks yet on Sunday.
It coincides
with Tuesday,
the anniversary of the city's
founding more than 1500 years ago
keeps me.
Also says more explosions
have been reported
across the Ukrainian capital
in recent hours.
There are no reports of injuries.
And the mayor wrote on Telegram
the air defense is at work.
CNN's Fred
Pleitgen is in Kiev
with more on these attacks.
Well, the Ukrainians are calling this
one of the largest attacks
using those Iranian
made to head drones
since Russia started its full on invasion
of Ukraine.
The Ukrainian military
is saying that a 59 showerheads
that were launched towards its territory.
They were able to take out 58.
So that's obviously a pretty
big success
rate there for the Ukrainian military
and its ever improving air defense.
Certainly the bulk of those drones
seem to be directed
at the Kiev region,
the Kiev and surrounding region.
And there was some damage
that was caused.
There were two people who were killed.
There were a lot of buildings
that were damaged as well.
Most of that,
the authorities say,
came from falling debris.
Also, there were some drone parts
apparently found near a warehouse
that had also sustained
some damage as well.
There was also
some pretty dramatic video
that came out from the Chernov region
that's in the north
of Ukraine
with border guards there
saying that they fired into the sky
when they saw and heard
those charred drones approaching.
A man should take one of them down
using small arms fire.
President Zelensky of Ukraine,
he came out
and he praised the forces
that are fighting against those drones,
fighting against missiles as well.
The Air Defense Force, as he called
them, heroes here in Ukraine
for keeping so many people
on the ground safe.
At the same time,
the Ukrainians pretty angry
at the Iranians
for giving those drones to the Russians.
In fact,
an adviser to Ukraine's
presidential administration,
he came out
and he warned the Iranians
that there could be retaliation.
Fred Pleitgen, CNN, Kiev.
Ukraine's military says it's destroyed
almost 70 aerial targets
launched by Russia
in its latest onslaught overnight.
That includes
more than three dozen cruise missiles
as well as Iranian made drones.
And a reconnaissance drone.
A police official in Kiev
says residential buildings
and infrastructure
in several districts were damaged,
but no one was killed or injured.
This comes just a day
after Ukraine said
Russia had launched
one of the largest drone attacks
to date against Quique.
CNN, Selma
Abdelaziz is here for more on this.
So there's a huge focus on drone
strikes on the capital.
Obviously, Russia
trying to make gains in the east.
What is the strategy here
to focus so much firepower on Kiev?
So overnight this
massive barrage yet again,
something like.
67 air targets,
according to Ukrainian
officials, taking out many of those,
as you mentioned, drones in missiles
The targets, Ukrainian officials
say, were military
infrastructure
and civilian infrastructure.
And this comes just a day
after on Sunday.
Ukraine says it witnesses
it witnessed the largest assault
by drones since the conflict began.
Nearly 60 drones,
most of those were whelming
number of those
shattered Iranian made drones being fired
across Ukraine.
Most of those drones, all
but one of those drones,
according to Ukrainian
officials, was taken out.
So what do we take from this
Yes, as you mentioned,
it seems that there is an uptick here
in Russian assaults, far
from those front lines on other areas,
civilian areas across Ukraine.
And yes, this terrifies
the citizens, the civilians of Ukraine.
But it also forces Ukraine
to use up valuable munitions.
One of those shadow drones,
they're very cheaply made.
One of those shadow drones
cost about 20 times
less than the missile
required to take out the drones.
You can see there
that Russia is forcing Ukraine
to use these valuable resources
at a time
that it really needs them
on the front line.
But Ukrainian officials
The lesson here is
air defenses are working.
The weapons that Neato has supplied,
that is saving lives.
And just briefly on the wider
geostrategic picture
here,
we've been hearing
some very alarming remarks
from the Belarussian leader,
Alexander Lukashenko, and his ever
closer union
with Russia when it comes to nuclear
and military assets.
Yes, some chilling comments
from Lukashenko.
Of course,
Belarus has essentially been used
as a satellite state
throughout this conflict
over the course of the last several days,
about week
Russia has began, begun,
rather, transferring
tactical nuclear weapons to Belarus.
Of course,
Ukraine and its allies,
the United States,
naito see that
as a violation of international law.
But Lukashenko
making these comments to state media
just the other day
saying that nuclear weapons
would be available to anyone who joins
the Russia Belarus alliance.
I actually want to read you the comment
because it is so alarming.
It's very simple.
Join the United States
United Union, state of Belarus,
and Russia.
That's all.
There will be nuclear weapons
for everyone.
And you can see how that begins
to worry international actors.
And I suppose he's
talking about post-Soviet
states like Kazakhstan.
Did you, Christiane, etc..
Some Abdulaziz, thank you so much.